welcome to exploring computing
today's video is web page example
captions so in this video we're going to
try and tie together everything you've
learned so far with an extensive example
you can see our web page here has some
fairly standard
formatting on particularly on the
headings
and then we've got those two images with
some captions underneath them and that's
really where the heart of this
example is going to be there's a number
of different
key topics we're going to be covering
first of all
you may be wondering how to decide
whether to use a type select or class
select or an id selector so we'll take a
look at that
you may also be wondering whether you
should use an external or an internal
style sheet
we'll see some examples of both of those
in action we'll also take a look at how
to use divs in a variety of different
ways
and also you'll notice that this
particular web page is centered in the
web browser and we'll show you how to do
that right at the end of this video okay
so
the first thing we're going to do is set
all our headings to sans serif
we'll talk about sans serif when we're
talking about
web design later in the quarter but just
for now
you can see the difference between the
standard appearance which is up on top
which has serifs
and then the bottom appearance which
does not have serifs and you kind of see
that bottom is a little bit cleaner
again we'll talk about it in more detail
another lecture now this particular
design choice we want to apply to all
the headings so
that means we want to use some sort of a
type selector
and here's our type selector i'm sending
the font family to sans serif
and then the next question is should
this go in an internal or external style
sheet and the way to be thinking about
internal versus external is
is this a particular style you are
likely to want to use throughout your
website for all the web pages on your
website or is this something specific to
just this web page now probably we're
going to want all the headings on our
website to look
the same and so this should go in an
external style sheet
all right in addition if you look at
that h1 you'll notice that
remember the h1 is the largest size
heading up at the top of the page
typically at the top of the page you'll
see that it's centered and i've changed
the colors it's pretty boring it's gray
but
i have i have changed the colors they're
gray
all right so here's how i've done that
i've set the background color to gray
i've set the foreground color to white
i've also set the text align to center
that's how that one's centered
i've set the font size to a specific
setting of my choice rather than using
the default of the web browser
i've also set the padding to 10 pixels
so let's take a close look at
the 10 pixels here what's the difference
between
setting the padding to 10 pixels versus
setting the margin to 10 pixels
well here we take a close-up of just the
center of that
heading we can see the difference so
notice at the top that's what we
actually have
notice there's a lot of gray above and
below the words
whereas with the bottom setting which
would just be if we set the
margin to 10 pixels rather than the
padding of 10 pixels
there's a much thinner gray border and
so what's happening here is that the
background color is based on the padding
so there's 10 pixels above and below
that's included
and covered by the background when i we
set the padding to 10 pixels
if we set the margin to 10 pixels that's
the stuff outside of the border we
haven't actually drawn a border here but
basically the background color will not
cover
anything outside of the border including
the margins and so that's why it appears
much thinner on the bottom setting
okay and assuming we want this h1 to
apply to
all the web pages on our website we
probably do we would put this in an
external style sheet
okay there's a couple more things we've
done with headings here they are right
here the h2s have lines above and below
them so we
set that with text decoration um we've
set the h3s to italics
and again we want this across all of our
web pages so this goes in the external
style sheet
if you look in the bottom left-hand
corner you see a very
small text there it's a little hard to
read here on the actual web page
it's still pretty small but it is
readable if we zoom in we'll see that
that
gives credit for where i actually got
the text the photos is
you will probably not be surprised here
are mine but
that text was taken from wikipedia and
so there's a couple questions to ask
first of all should i use a div for this
or should i use a paragraph or should i
use something else
and should i use a class for this or an
id and
in this particular case i don't think
that there's a right answer
i used a paragraph for it but if you
wanted to use a div for it that that
would make sense
i gave it an id because i was assuming
that there would be only one credits on
the web page but you know if you thought
you might
want to use this credit setting in other
places as well maybe you want to put
credits on the
photographs it might make sense to set
this up as a class and you can see that
for this particular id i set the font
size to extra extra small
and i also set the font family to sans
serif
so the text of the the body
except for the headings and a few other
places is
serif but specifically the headings and
this credit section is sans-serif
okay let's go back to our big picture
here and
as i mentioned the main thing the big
topic here that we're going to be
talking about is these
images so let's take a closer look at
these images
so if you look at the images you'll
notice that there is actually the image
and underneath that there's a caption
uh there's a border surrounding the
image and the caption and the caption is
centered and in italic
so we want to figure out how to do all
of those
okay the first thing i'm going to do is
i want to treat the image and the
caption as a group
so i'm going to go ahead and create a
div and place
both the img tag and the caption into
that div
and i want these style elements to be
the same for all the images
and so i'm going to go ahead and create
a class if we only want the styles to
apply to single image we could give it
an id
but if we think it's going to be
something we want on multiple images go
ahead and give it a class
and here's my initial take here you can
see i've created a div
and i've given a class photo and then
also i want to do some additional
styling on the caption and so i've given
that a class as well
class caption i think that i'm going to
use the same styling information
for all the different captions so i want
to give it a class
i've also put a height and a width in
the img tag
for each of these images this is
actually so when the web page
loads what's going to happen here is the
html file is going to be received first
uh the html file will probably refer
well in this case we'll definitely refer
to an external style sheet it will also
refer to a bunch of imgs
while the web browser is waiting for
that style sheet to download
while in particular it's waiting for
those images to download it does not
necessarily know how big the images are
so what will happen is you'll get a
small postage stamp size
icon showing where the image is supposed
to appear and then later when it figures
out how big those images actually are
it will resize the web page so by
putting a specific
hyphen width here on the img tag i am
telling the web browser to go ahead and
reserve
space for that image so we'll go ahead
and create
a blank area for the image as big as the
space i've specified
and when the image finally downloads it
will go ahead and fill it into that
space
you don't necessarily have to specify
here on the img you could just specify
it on the cast getting style sheets on
the theory that
until the cascading style sheet is
downloaded anyway it's not going to know
how to lay out the web pages we will be
talking about extensively about how to
layout web pages in the
lecture there's also some tricks that
you can play with
different
with different pixel densities on your
images
uh and we will may talk about that in
another lecture it gets actually fairly
complicated if you want to have
oh here's the image that i want to use
if this is in a low density situation
where
you know maybe it's a mid-range display
or a mid-range television an hdtv
it's been displaying on versus this is a
super high quality
retinal display on an ipad or something
like that
and i want two different images one
where which takes up a lot of space and
has a lot of pixels for that retinal
display and then maybe another one
for for the standard quality display
we could talk about that in another
lecture
all right here's the rules that i'm
going to use for the photo and the
caption
you can see that i've put a border
around
the photo and i've added a bit of
padding
and then i've told the caption it should
be line center and the font style should
be italic
and this works for our little image here
uh this is my um old karen terry molly
the flow pep
and this is in the middle of a dorm
staff meeting uh nobody's paying
attention and she's trying to sneak the
snacks off the table while we're all
talking
so this works totally fine for that but
on the other image
uh this is what we want the other image
to appear as and it turns out it doesn't
actually work
this is what happens so what happened
here why did it work on one but not the
other well
what happened here is the image has a
specific width
but the text does not and what happens
is
because text has no natural width other
than
you know however long your sentence or
paragraph is it will expand to take up
as much space as available so
the a two month karen terry puppy
escapes from an enclosure
that just expanded out it said i am just
going to take as much space as is
available until i can appear on one line
or until i fill the entire web browser
window so that's a problem
so our solution for this is we're going
to provide a specific
width on that caption
and so let's go back to our questions
here should this be
specified as a class or an id thing
and should this be internal versus
external well my thinking here
is each of the images
may have a different width so this isn't
something that's going to be in common
for
all of my images now it's possible
you're running
some sort of newspaper and you just have
a couple standard widths for all your
images so in that case you might use a
class but in this particular case i
figured
all my images could be a random width
and so
i'm going to go ahead and create a rule
specifically for this
image and so this means i'm going to
give it an id
and then as far as internal versus
external well if this is something
that's going to be in common across
multiple web pages that's external
in this case as i said i'm assuming my
widths are going to be different from
one image to another
and that's specific just to this image
and so there's no reason to put that in
an external style sheet that's going to
get downloaded by all my other web pages
on my website this is specific to
just this image and so
i'm going to go ahead and provide a
width
i'm going to put it in the internal
style sheet so you know there's my style
start stop tags this is in the internal
style sheet
i you can see that i'm actually going to
put the width on the caption
but i'm going to put the id on the
surrounding div and the idea here is
you know maybe there's going to be some
other things down the road that are
going to be specific to this uh this
particular image caption
setup so by putting the id on
that whole div i get a little bit more
flexibility
uh and so this particular rule combines
the id
it needs to be in the escape photo
followed by the space followed by
the dot caption so you recall this is
actually a descendant selector it says
this will apply to anything that is
contained within a element
with the id escape photo and
somewhere within that escape photo div
if there's some other element inside of
that escape photo div that has the
class captioned this will apply to it
and so i went ahead and said
okay that caption that fits it or if
there's any other captions that fit this
particular
rule which there aren't in this case uh
that's gonna be width 200
and then i figured you know we might
want to change the caption on the other
photo at some point so i might as well
go ahead and specify width for that
and this is pretty common practice the
idea being
you're the website designer you're the
web page designer
somebody else might change the contents
of the web page at another time and so
you should be thinking longer term
like okay right now the image underneath
right now that caption under the other
photo that's not white enough to cause
problems but it could be changed by a
text editor later
and they might not understand how to fix
html css problems so better to
just go ahead and specify both the
widths right now
okay we've got photos on the left and
the right um
this is seems like something that we
would want to have on all our web pages
so that suggests it should be a class
and so i've gone ahead and specified it
on my
divs here i have a right photo and a
left photo class
notice that the class actually specifies
that it is both a photo
which we saw the rules for before and a
right photo or a left photo so
i didn't really mention this previously
but you can list multiple classes
on your class attribute value pair in
your tags
so i think this is a little odd i think
they should have separated them by
commas but they didn't so just list as
many classes as you want just separate
them by spaces
and then here's the rules for the left
and the right photo
basically i'm floating to the left or
floating to the right and then i'm
specifically setting a margin either on
the left or the right
basically the margin is on the opposite
side of where it's floating
so the idea here is it will be flush to
the left
and then on the right side where the
text is flowing alongside
i want a little bit of a margin between
the photo and the text or
if the photo has flirted to the right i
want it flush on the right side of the
web page
with a little bit of margin between on
the left where the text is flowing
alongside
okay you'll also notice that the web
page is centered in the web browser this
is pretty common
how do you do that usually what you're
going to do is you're going to add an
extra div
the div is going to surround absolutely
everything
in the body so you can see i have the
outer body tag
and then inside of the body tag i have a
div i've given it the id
all and everything in the web page is in
that inner
div and then what i'm going to do is
i'm going to write a rule for that inner
div
and here it is i say oh this is for all
and
i gave it a specific width i said the
entire content should fill
a thousand pixels and then i set the
margin to auto
margin auto allows the web browser to
choose the margins on its own and what
that will usually do for the left and
the right margin is just
even out the left and right margin and
place the item in the center so that
gives us this nice effect
another thing that these are sometimes
used for
these outer divs are sometimes used for
is if you want to put a box around the
entire
webpage you could go ahead and put a
border around it at all and you would
get a nice little
back uh border around the entire thing
okay um that's just about it the last
thing i wanted to mention is
this use of divs uh is super flexible
we'll take a look at this again next
lecture and you get to play around with
a little bit in the next homework
assignment
uh but i did want to mention for the
more advanced students the students that
are planning to actually
start creating real websites
particularly if you're planning to do
this in a professional setting
you should be aware that html5 has added
some new tags which
can be used in place of these divs these
pretty much will do the same thing as
the divs that i created here
the div for the caption the div for the
uh the image and the caption together
they don't generally have any styling
information on their own but they are
used to tell the web browser the sort of
semantic information about
what this tag is supposed to be and
these can be very helpful for
supporting viewers with accessibility
problems
particularly if somebody can't see the
screen
they're using what's called a a reader
where the web browser is reading the
contents of them these can be super
helpful to let those
readers know what's going on so in this
particular case there's a figure
and a fig caption um tag
and so these could replace my two divs
the div for the caption obviously
where i said class equals caption that
could be replaced by fig caption
and then the outer one with a photo that
could have been replaced by a figure
and then here's a list of uh some of the
other semantic elements i mentioned a
couple of these i think before
so there's an article uh a side is sort
of like um if you've seen those
textbooks where there's a sort of like a
blue box
you can kind of see my lame version of
that in some of the chapters from the
cs105 course reader where i just
mark hey this is should go site but i
didn't actually put it in an external
box
details section summary and time
and then these might actually do
something
for uh the web browser on the bottom
here
nav that's super helpful for
people again that can't actually read
your web page or
are having the web page read to them so
nav indicates that a section is actually
a navigational section so if you've got
you know those we'll talk about this
later but if you've got that common
design where you've got a sidebar
or a top navigation bar where you say
hey here are some elements
other here are some other web pages on
my website that you can click on
by having that nav there you can let
the web browser know hey don't read this
section
to the person that's
visiting my web page until they
specifically say okay i'm done listening
to what the contents of the web page are
what are my navigation options and then
the web browser can be like oh
i see you have that nav section now's
where i'm going to go ahead and read the
nav section to
my viewer and then there's a header and
a footer
which could be potentially used by the
web browser due to something special in
the top and the bottom i don't think it
actually is used for anything right now
it's just a
another tag that you can use that you
can give style rules to
the same way i've given star rules to my
div with
class equals photo and my div with
caption
so these are all different options and
again by providing a little bit more
semantic information
you'll make it a little bit easier for
the web browser to tell what it is
you're trying to do you'll also
potentially make it easier for people
like if you create a web design let's
say you go this actually happens to
uh some of my students you go to some
some company let's see you start up a
new non-profit with a bunch of friends
nobody knows how to make a web page
you're it
and so you go and make the web page but
you might want other people to be able
to modify that web page so by by using
these special tags you can let people
know
what the different parts of your html
file are to be used for you're providing
them
a little bit more guidance uh in terms
of what the individual sections are
rather than just having a bunch of divs
okay that's it um i'll talk to you guys
soon
we've got a lot more cool web stuff
coming we've got
extensive discussion on layout so you
know i think this is
already a pretty interesting web page
but um we've actually
got uh an extensive discussion on
layouts followed by
how to use the the technologies i'm
going to be teaching you to recreate
parts of the
new york times web page and the
washington post webpage so you can look
forward to that
i'll talk to you soon
you